hello everybody this is Peter Cooper
from the NCBI welcome to today's webinar
on how to quickly retrieve sequences
from NCBI during the webinar if you have
a question please type it in the
questions pod my colleague Tao is here
and he will try to answer them in real
time while we go through the webinar and
if there are some particularly relevant
ones for everyone I'll take some time at
the end to try to answer those for any
questions that we have we're gonna put
answers up in a document and they're
gonna be available after the webinar
linked to our webinars page so I'm gonna
go ahead and start the webinar we're
gonna talk today
in sort of basic terms about how to
quickly retrieve sequences from NCBI my
name of course is Peter Cooper as I said
earlier and you can always write to me
with any questions about this material
Peter Cooper at NIH gov and I'll show
you some other contact addresses at the
end of this so we're basically gonna
learn how to display and download
sequences using the NCBI web pages which
sounds pretty basic but it's something
that a lot of people are not aware of
how to do that we're also going to show
you how to just bookmark sequences and
things like that using direct URLs and
then we're going to switch over to the
command line using eunuch Linux UNIX and
Linux we're going to use the utilities
very briefly and then we're going to
switch over to the e direct programs
which is a much simpler way of doing
that so we're going to talk first about
accessing sequences on the web and I'm
gonna show you a few slides and then
we'll go live and demonstrate how to do
these kinds of things so when you're
downloading sequences or accessing
sequences at NCBI you're going to search
for them through the system called the
entre system most people are aware of
the system they may not be aware the
name we've sort of gotten away from
calling it that but that's the name that
we call it here at NCBI we're gonna be
talking about using two main sequence
databases today I'm going to focus only
on nucleotide also called new core it
doesn't really matter which one you use
but the same things that i'ma show you
applied to the protein databases so
we're going to talk about nucleotide but
the same applies to protein sequences as
well so if you go to the Andre system
there are some display formats you can
get to first we'll run a search get some
sequences you see by default the summer
format and you can get these various
formats displayed for you GenBank fast
day and things like that
Jamaican fast they're the two that I'm
going to emphasize and those are the
direct URLs there on the right hand side
of this slide to those web pages notice
is just the entree I mean the NCBI base
URL followed by the name of the database
we'll come back to that in a minute when
we talk about bookmarking sequences so
the two common formats that people
really want run into the most in our
site or GenBank GenBank is the default
view that you get in the entree system
it's human readable and as a header it
has a sequence annotation and then it
has the sequence itself and it's the the
same format that's used on the GenBank
FTP release of course in sequence you're
going to be looking at is going to be a
reference sequence but this format is
still to GenBank format and then there's
fast date and this is probably the
format that most people want when
they're coming to get a sequence it
basically is a real simple format it has
a title on one line with a greater than
sign that starts the title and then it
has a sequence on the subsequent lines
this is basically a universal format for
sequence analysis programs and you know
we could have a text format version of
it that you can just copy and paste
really easily even if you have multiple
sequences I'll show you that in a few
minutes
one thing to notice about these is that
you can't download these directly from
the web browser using the browser's
function in the file menu and the way
you get around that is use the send to
menu that's in the upper right hand
corner of the entree display pages so if
I click on that it opens up and it gives
me a bunch of radio buttons that I can
choose if you want to download the
complete record you can do that we'll
come back to this in a moment you can
also get the coding sequences or the
gene features you know things that are
annotated on the record if we choose the
file it's a destination then we can just
press that create file button and we
will download this in the text format
the options here that are the two the
three really that I'm going to talk
about are GenBank the one we've already
mentioned GenBank full this is a special
format that you're going to have to deal
with
large sequence records because by
default big sequence records like human
chromosome records will not have the
sequence in them unless you specifically
ask for GenBank full and fast a which is
the most important one for downloading
and there are a number of other
structured formats here that we won't go
into today I also identify our lists
because we're going to be focusing on
getting the sequences another topic I
just wanted to mention is the ability to
bookmark sequences so there's sort of a
standard way that you can link to a
record in the aundre system it's the
ncbi base URL the database name and the
ID and that's at the bottom of this
slide so for example if I wanted to link
directly to the nucleotide sequence like
this one at the top notice that I could
just have the base URL the database
which you can put nucleotide or Nucor
here and then the identifier which is
the accession number likewise I can add
this little feature at the end report
equals fast a to get the fast a sequence
I have to put a question mark there and
then report fast a and then finally you
can link to the text record by format
text and notice you can do this with
more than one record okay so that's all
well and good but mostly that's for
displaying things what we want to be
able to do is to access sequences
directly without using a web browser to
get them locally for us to use so the
standard way of doing that is something
called the entre utilities or the
e-utilities this is ncbi api that uses
urls to access the system these can be
incorporated into scripts
basically there's a base URL then
there's a bunch of server-side programs
that you run they do require that you
write a custom wrapper script to
antegrade search and retrieval so an e
fetch example which would basically do
the same thing that we just saw on the
bookmark links there is listed at the
bottom of the slide and you basically
have your base URL here which is kind of
long then you have the CGI program
you fetch then you give it the database
you're using the ID that you want and
the return type in this case is
fascinating that would give you the fast
a
formatted record for this particular
NCBI reference sequence that's fine if
you are really comfortable writing
scripts there is a set of scripts at
NCBI has produced call Andre direct this
is basically a command line version of
the utilities and so these basically are
programs that run on a UNIX or unix-like
operating system and you can basically
use them to do things like sequence
search and retrieval we're gonna be
focusing mainly today on retrieval which
means we're going to be using this
program here called a fetch
there's a lot more to entre direct but
we're not going to go into that today
and why do you want to use this it lets
you get the sequences directly which
batch access and you don't have to go
through a read browser and most
importantly there's no scripting
required so this is a slide from a talk
that I give about a direct but you know
basically we're going to be looking at
that sort of center section where we're
basically going to perform a search just
basic search the same one we're gonna do
on the web in a few minutes and then
we're going to use 'if edge to download
this thing and of course there's a lot
more to this you have a parser in there
if you get the XML format you can parse
that if you want to know more about how
to use e direct we did a hour-long
webinar on this and you can watch the
recording on our youtube channel by
following the link in this slide so how
do these programs work they work in a
very similar way to the way Andre works
so we're going to run a search using the
Easter's program this will put some
things up in our entre history which we
don't need to worry about really and
then I'm going to use the UNIX pipe to
put the output of this into this program
e fetch and I'm going to get some format
down in this case this is real simple I
just asked for the accession numbers and
you know for the sequence databases
there are lots of formats available in
Contra direct these are many other
formats you would see on that pulldown
list on the web in the send to menu
there are lots of additional ones there
are some additional ones here because
you have sort of a an XML format and a
text format for example for the GenBank
flat file when we're working with these
you'll see that if you want to know what
the options are for example for youth
that you just type the name of the
program
and then help in order to use these you
have to install them and that
information on how to install the
programs I'm not going to go over that
today but it's very straightforward if
you go to the on trade direct help
documents which will point out to you in
a little bit you should be able to
install them real simply on any
unix-like operating system and for more
information about you direct you know
you should go to the really good place
to go for some recipes for how to do
certain things with the direct is this a
direct cookbook that's available on the
NCBI hackathons getup site on the URL
for it is here in the center of this
slide okay so what I want to do now are
some live demonstrations of how to
manage these kinds of things on the web
and then move over to the command line
all right so I'm going to escape out of
the slides and I'm gonna go over here to
the web browser and I'm going to go
through some examples so let's work with
a particular set of genes and gene
products what I'm gonna do first is
we're gonna get human sequences so I'm
gonna focus on human eggs I'm gonna do
an organism field and search and I'm
just going to type the name of a gene
aprt which is adenine phospho right
Boesel transferase and we're gonna
search the nucleotide database you can
get that from the pulldown list here or
if you google that you can find me and
see the nucleotide homepage directly so
I have already my had my refseq filter
on you you can I can take that off and
you'll see the difference that you get
if you don't have that on so I get 22
but I'm gonna reduce it down to 7 by
using this refseq filter and so you this
is interesting just to notice what kind
of records we got we got the two
transcript variants from a PRT
we got this refseq gene record which is
a standalone record that represents that
genomic region plus some flanking
sequence on either side of the gene we
also got some additional refseq gene
records and that's because the flanking
sequence contains parts of these genes
here which are also on chromosome 16 and
of course we got the entire chromosome
16 record here two versions of it one
from the primary assembly inland from
the CHM one underscore one dot one
assembly so what i want to work with her
just the first three
sequences
I don't want to have to deal with
downloading that human chromosome
although we could do that and we'll show
you some things here so those in the
pulldown list here I can change the
format quite easily I could change it to
GenBank and we get all the records here
in GenBank format human readable lots of
details about the annotation on these
records or we can choose fast eh and
there are the three records in fats they
format so what a lot of people do is
come here they select these you would
have to select them one at a time and
copy and paste them into a text file or
sometimes they paste them into the blast
sequence similarity search tool notice
that you don't need to do that by the
way you can get a set of sequences on
the webpage here and click the run blast
button and it will just take the
accessions put them in the blast form
and you're ready to go so you don't
really need to do this in that
particular case this is still a bit
inconvenient so there is another more
convenient way to get these if you
wanted to select all three sequences at
once there's a fast a text version here
and so there they are
and if I select and copy and paste these
I'll just get these and text format here
so in a way that's convenient but it's
not very convenient if I was trying to
do this with say hundreds of sequences
so in order to do that you need to use
the send to menu on the right hand side
and of course as I pointed out to you if
you tried to save these with the web
browser function it won't work you'll
just get the web page with all that HTML
stuff and you don't want that so we can
use the send to menu here choose file as
a destination and so we can quickly
download the fast day format you've
already seen what that looks like you
could also download the genbank format
if I was dealing with that chromosome 16
record I could get the GenBank full
format as well there's a bunch of other
formats here which we won't go into
today these are basically structured
formats of various kinds you can also
get identifier lists and then you we
also have relatively recently we put the
GFF which is
looking at the annotation one useful
thing here is to get the coding
sequences just to show you how that
works
let me just go back and grab one of
these real quick I'm going to retrieve
this sequence this is a transcript
variant one and notice that there's a
feature on the feature table called the
CBS CBS so I can highlight it right here
CBS starts with start codon and ends
with the stop codon so this is the part
of this messenger RNA sequence that is
translated into protein and so we can
get those for all the records in our
list if we want to for things like
messenger RNAs that's going to be nice
and simple one coding region coding
sequence but for this gene record here
we're going to have several of them
corresponding to perhaps different
transcripts Fleiss variants that are
annotated on the gene record and also
the fact that this particular record is
going to have parts of other genes
besides a PR key and so I just to show
you a download format let's go ahead and
do that so let's go to send to I'm going
to send the coding sequences and I'm
going to download fast a nucleotide and
I'll put that on my desktop I'll just
call it CD s dot txt now I'm gonna go
back here and I'm just gonna drop it
into this text editor and so you can see
that you get these nice coding regions
here with a very nice structured death
line that tells you what gene it is
where it is and those kinds of things
you can also see the various coding
regions that are present on this
refseqgene record so these are very
handy for what coding regions are on
there some cases some of these are
partial and some of them are complete to
complete one of course is for the a PRT
gene okay so we already talked I think
it's officially in the slides about how
to bookmark these sequences you can
easily follow the instructions in the
slides what I'm gonna do now is go over
to the command line to show you a couple
of things there so okay so I'm now
logged on to a UNIX system at the NCBI
and so I can do various things here one
of the things I could do is to put one
of those utilities URLs and do that
that's not particularly constructive
because it's not something that you
really want to have to do what you
really want to be able to do is to use
the programs you search and you fetch to
get things and so let's go ahead and
talk about that so let's first reproduce
the search that we had in the slides a
minute ago and so just to save myself
some typing I'm gonna get it out of this
text file that I have here and this is
up on the FTP site by the way so if you
want to reproduce these things yourself
you can so let me just put this in here
first now I change the search slightly
so that it has a more complicated lot
slightly more complicated search so it
says the search aprt and the title and
that's to make sure that I just get
those three sequences because I don't
really want to deal with the human
sequence the human chromosome sequence
now there is a UNIX pipe and I want the
format accession so I got the three
accession numbers that I'm was
interested in before I can just use my
up arrow key to get that back again and
I could use get one of the other formats
that we talked about it's fast a and if
I want to just to make it nicer what
will happen is it's just going to dump
it out to the screen I could put it to a
file if I want to we could just call it
a pea
aarti dot passed a nucleic acid if I
want to let's go ahead and do that and
we can just take a look at what's in the
file by using the UNIX program more so
you can see I have the fast a sequences
I'm just going to scroll through it here
for the records the three records that
we talked about now suppose I want to
know you know what are the format's
strings do I need to use to get the
various formats that we talked about for
any of the redirect programs just type
its name and a dash and the word helped
then I'm going to pipe this into the
program more so we can scroll through it
so here are the various format arguments
that you can use for the different
databases the one we're going to be
interested in is the sequence databases
of course and so you can see here the
various ones we've already used fast day
we get asked for the coding region even
the amino acid sequence so even if
you're starting with a nucleotide
sequence and I should have pointed this
out on the webpage you could ask for the
amino acid sequence corresponding
translation or you could get the CDs
nucleic acid sequence which is the one
we got down from the webpage and here
are all the other possibilities clear my
screen so instead of format fast day we
could type nucleic acid and I'll just
let that scroll so you can see it looks
just like the thing that we downloaded a
minute ago and so you can see some of
the different coding regions here
including the ones there at the end from
the this is the refseq gene record in
here the coding sequences from the mRNA
sequences now one thing you can also do
and you can do this on the web to
bookmark you know regions of sequences
if you want to but you can use a seek
start and seek stop arguments here to
get a region of a sequence and so let's
do something that's fairly big let's try
chromosome 16 and I can dump out a
region of chromosome 16 that contains
the aprt gene and we'll get it in
GenBank format just so we can take a
look at browse through and find the
various gene features that are on there
sort of save myself some typing well
what the heck why don't I type in so I'm
gonna go to the database that I want to
use is and I can use nucleotide so DB is
nucleotide ID I have to know the
accession number that I want but I do
know what it is it's chromosome 16 and
those are pretty easy to remember I
don't have to use the version I do have
to use the right number of zeros though
now I can give it some arguments and
these are things that I determined ahead
of time where the genes are that I'm
interested in so I can pass the argument
seek start and seek stop and then we can
ask for a format today so give us a gym
Bank flat file format check my numbers
here and this takes a minute so let's
let it run there for a second because
it's retrieving a very large record
basically tries to get the whole thing
down before it does anything it's worth
more well that's happening let me go
back to the slides for a moment so we
showed you how to access sequences using
the web system we bookmark some URLs and
then we show you how to use command line
access through using e direct to get
sequences this last slide here has a
bunch of places where you can go to get
more information about e direct and the
other things we've talked about today
and let me go back and make sure if this
thing came back just before I leave this
slide to remind you that if you have any
questions about NCI resources you can
write to us at info info at NCBI NLM th
go if you have questions about webinars
in general the webinars program can be
reached at webinars at NCBI NLM h gov
okay let's see if this is finished yep
so I downloaded a portion of chromosome
16 it's a fifty three thousand seven
hundred sixty-five base pairs and it
tells me what the region is so I
actually got the complementary strand
that's why I put the seek start was
actually higher than the seat stop
because the gene we're interested in it
happens to be on the complement but I
get the complete feature table here
I'll just use more to find the APR key
teen and here it is neither some mr
these are the two splice variants that
are annotated on the record and there's
the coding region and so on and so forth
okay so let me stop there and we'll have
some time to answer a few questions if
anybody has any okay let me take a look
at them okay so it's like we answered
some of these in the in the process of
the webinar one question is the range of
an accession maybe more than one range
you could do that and that's you can use
a colon to separate the two accession
numbers the range may be talking about
the one where I showed you where you can
have a start and a stop this question is
an interesting one does it split the
coding regions into exons that can be
easily identified no it doesn't in that
particular format now there is if we if
you looked at the feature table for one
of the reference sequences the mRNA
refseq that I looked at those do have
the exons annotated on them and so do
the refseq gene records you wouldn't
need to parse them out in another way so
there was a clarification about the
range can I ask for range of a sequence
more than one range of the sequence at
the same time and the answer to that as
far as I know is no you can ask for a
range you know it's starting to stop but
you can't get multiple segments of a
sequence I'll look into that and when we
put the document up I'll see if I can
find the answer to that question but I
don't think that's possible if I
understand the question correctly
okay so let's wrap this up it's 12:30
thanks everybody for coming and we'll
see you next time